on this next test that I'm going to show
you it's called V a K s test okay and
the AKS test is Internet Essentials
anyone if you're observing you're not a
KS it stands for I grow up
hey y'all see now just like before three
mathematicians the AKS test right it's a
massive massive improvement on fastest
as you'll see okay and it also has some
kind of cool implications right so he's
the language let me write it out for you
first and then we'll unpack it okay
again we're testing a number P is P okay
it sounds as I go to a remarkably
similar to Thermage test okay here's
what we going to calculate X minus 1 to
the power P and X is mother is not Emma
it's gonna be um we just leave it as a
variable and we're going to subtract X
to the power of P minus 1 okay so when
you do this so this is a polynomial
you've got to do some expansion of the
brackets and all that kind of thing when
you get a result at the end and then you
do this then you simplify okay there's
going to be a whole bunch of
coefficients within the polynomial okay
you remember what coefficients are for
something like say it is okay your
coefficients in this case will be one
five and six
okay so when you expand this out for
some number P you will have coefficients
like this okay so what you want the way
to know where the P is prime or not is
that all coefficients
every single one will be just like with
famous test multiples of P okay if P is
prime then when you evaluate this and
you simplify out all the coefficients
would be
fools of pee mmm all right let's test it
out shall we let's start with them
because they're doing an expansion you
will start with an even smaller prime
number let's go with three because
that's small enough to be workable but
large enough to be interesting so we're
going to test P equals three okay so I'm
going to write out X minus 1 cubed right
minus X cubed minus 1 has this kind of
neat symmetry to it which is nice the
whole powers and the brackets
independent the subtraction as well so
let's evaluate this thing ok now you can
go ahead and you can actually you can
expand this out you can say well that's
gonna be X minus 1 times X minus 1 whole
square which is it's a perfect square so
that's that's a good result so you can't
that's a plus 1 that's a very result so
you can go ahead and do that but there's
another trick you can use if you go
ahead and you do this what you would end
up with it is I'll make sure I get my
numbers right what you get is these
numbers here 1 3 3 what does anyone
recognize them okay so if you draw
high-schools
triangle tada there are the coefficients
right there okay so that's where the
numbers are don't forget there's signs
in you so watch out for this all right
now I can do this subtraction business
at the end ok so what am I going to end
up with let's see can I lose the X cubed
at the front so that's gonna go and
there's a negative 1 here take away
negative 1 so those are going to go yeah
what are we left with well actually this
guy and sure enough all the coefficients
are multiples of three
okay so for the purposes of this test it
doesn't matter that their name oh yeah
we don't really tend to talk about
negative numbers when we're considering
a prize we're really we're really in
this territory okay because when we
think about the visibility the visit is
big weed when you think that negative
numbers because then think about this
right
Islam is is five-prime right it's like
well its factors are 1 & 5 oh but wait
what about negative 1 and negative 5 now
I have no factors over my universe so so
for that reason we don't really can sit
on negative numbers as part of the
equation does that make sense it's not
arbitrary it's just not particularly
useful to consider man okay so let's see
there's a guy just interesting oh just
fetching let's just go to the next one
right how do we miss one okay that's the
next road right so when you think about
the next test when you do this out this
is testing you for a prime right have a
look at the numbers up all of these
coefficients going to be multiples of
four and the answer is no because four
is not prime four is composit right have
a look at the next row its Pascal's
triangle you can work out the next
search for me can't you 1 5 10 10
symmetry
so when I do this process right you see
what this does here what is this - like
if we were doing this test for P equals
5 all you're doing really is you're
taking off the first one and you're
taking off the last one right
so really all you're doing this so
another way of saying the AKS test is
rather noisier than your polynomials
right another way say is P prime is pre
prime well is the is the P F rotor of
Pascal's triangle is it full of
multiples of P and if it is it's prime
okay let's just let's just go on a
little bit and see what happened like if
I go to the next row it's gonna be 1/6
of Yukio right seeks what's the next one
15 and then 20 and then see the tree
right so all these numbers multiples of
6 course not because 6 is compass it
right but then look at the next row come
on give it a go one 720 135 oh my you
serious yeah you bet I'm serious if
you're really what go ahead to R or 11
just to freak yourself out okay it's
pretty perfect now he's the really cool
thing on two things number one you can't
took it for granted I went from this
line to this line right and I just told
you that that was the coefficient okay
just to beat content you go ahead and
take this thing you put that on
there's only gonna be six terms or to
collapse into four okay just satisfy
yourself that that really is what the
expansion is okay so we think number one
is why should these coefficients in dark
as these numbers the second thing is
right so after you establish that well
why are little B's numbers multiples of
seven and when we get down to the 11th
road while all of these numbers going
three multiples of 11 now if you hold on
next two years of maths not that it's
part of the syllabus but you will learn
the maths that will help you solve and
prove why these are multiples are gonna
be both 11 mobile so 13 multiples of 17
and on and on it's quite profound so you
can see the AKS test massive improvement
over for most tests right much much
faster